new york
willkommen bei vielen kassen sein
nächstes thema ist nämlich jetzt wie
schreibe ich an der hausarbeit und
philosophie im fach philosophie
ich muss ja auch ein schreiben nach
wittlich der punkt ist der hast du dir
tipps woran man sich orientieren kann
wie man am besten eine hausarbeit und
schreibt ganz grob seine standpunkte
ich habe mir viele gedanken gemacht ich
selbst habe ja auch mal hausarbeiten
geschrieben ist es noch gar nicht so
lange her und in der philosophie ist da
was ganz spezielles die philosophie lebt
davon dass man sich eigene gedanken
machen dass man originell ist mal neue
fragen aufwirft und meine erfahrung ist
die daß man dann besonders gute
philosophische hausarbeiten schreibt
wenn man eine interessante leitfrage
entwickelt als ein problem erkennt in
einem text zum beispiel häufig hier vor
allem in münchen haben das ja mit
klassischen texten der
philosophiegeschichte zu tun also einen
text wieder eine ganz interessanten
fragestellungen konfrontiert
der vorteil ist davon der dass wir nicht
mehr den gesamten text gleichermaßen
berücksichtigen müssen sondern unter
einem ganz bestimmten gesichtspunkt
lesen können was uns die arbeit
erleichtert wir müssen ja alles
gleichermaßen berücksichtigt das heißt
wir haben also die möglichkeit nur
bestimmte zitat herauszufinden und
müssen ja und dann über diese partien zu
schreiben es ist praktisch eine
selektion man man man wählt sich das aus
was wichtig ist man muss wenigen angebot
das es momentan geht und das führt mich
auch zum anderen punkt dass häufig der
krise also diese fähigkeit das wichtige
von weniger wichtigem zu unterscheiden
das ist heute so was von gefragt wenn
wir auch außerhalb der philosophie uns
aufhalten
wir werden beeinflusst mit massen an
informationsmaterial datenmüll häufig
wir müssen selektieren wir müssen
schauen was ist wichtig weiß es nicht so
wichtig das heißt wir müssen prioritäten
setzen
worauf kommt es an genau was ist
entscheidend was interessiert mich jetzt
und was lasse ich außen vor
und das kann man sehr gut sagen im
kleinen konzentriert trainieren
texte text ist auch informationen die
informationsflut wenn man kant oder
häkeln ist das bombardiert uns wir
müssen in diesem text uns orientieren
wir müssen da durch manövrieren ist kann
man nur dadurch machen dass wir ganz
spezifischen fokus auf den text lesen
und damit andere dinge ausdenken das ist
nichts anderes als wenn wir heutzutage
im internet 50 e-mails am tag bekommen
wir müssen aber jetzt zum letzten punkt
weil es ist in anderen fächern ja sehr
standard dass man ganz viel
sekundärliteratur haben versagt dazu
das kann später mal wichtig sein für
masterarbeiten doktorarbeit oder sogar
habilitationen aber wenn es um ganz
normale haus arbeiten gehen würde ich
davon er ab haben gleich auf die
sekundärliteratur überzugehen
die gefahr besteht darin dass wir dann
abhängig werden von dem gedanken anderer
und gar nicht mehr eigene these
entwickeln können deswegen mein tipp an
anfänger und philosophie erstmal sich
eigene gedanken machen versuchen ein
leid probleme zu identifizieren ein oder
zwei leitfragen auf den text zu
applizieren auch keine großen vergleiche
zwischen verschiedenen philosophen
herzustellen das ist viel zu
anspruchsvoll beschränken weniger ist
mehr konzentration auf einen leitfrage
und erst dann wenn man eine eigene these
hat oder die idee dann in die
sekundärliteratur übergehen und dann
schauen was sagen andere dazu und
gegebenenfalls kann ich dann im
idealfall in der diskussion mit der
sekundärliteratur in ihren positionen
eintreten wenn wir die sache jetzt
spannung ok dann danke für deine tipps
und anregungen
ich wünsche allen leuten wie jetzt da
raus zu tun haben mit einer hausarbeit
viel erfolg und bin gespannt auf die
nächste folge bei philo gast